All right, here's a hack to writing copy
that almost no one tells you. You should
be the target audience of the product
you are trying to sell. For example, I
like to write in the golf niche. The
reason I like to write in the golf niche
is cuz I play golf. So, I understand the
pains, the desires, the dreams, the
hopes, and the things that golfers won't
say, but they think. And so, what I do
is I take all those things that I know
because I'm in the target market, and I
write them in a sales letter, or I write
them in emails, and they go like
bananas. They sell like crazy because I
know them. I am them. And that is a huge
hack for you as a copywriter because you
don't have to do any market research.
You are the market, and that's 80% of
great copy is understanding the pains,
hopes, desires, and dreams, fears, all
of that stuff of your target market. If
you nail that, you will make more money
than you've ever made in your life.